[Música]
hola soy natalia cabrera y les doy la
bienvenida aquí a américa el espacio de
france 24 para revisar en profundidad
las historias de nuestro continente
el covent 19 afecta
desproporcionadamente a los pueblos
indígenas y amenaza con su desaparición
en colombia brasil y perú las tasas de
letalidad de la enfermedad en las zonas
en las que habitan duplican el promedio
nacional las mujeres de la amazonía
peruana se unieron para demandar al
gobierno por vulnerables el derecho a la
vida les contamos desde el imán
y el duelo en argentina por la muerte
del dibujante quino el creador de
mafalda joaquín salvador lavado murió a
los 88 años en su natal mendoza en
buenos aires- el monumento en su honor
se llenó de flores y las redes sociales
de homenajes
y a menos de un mes para las elecciones
presidenciales en eeuu tenemos un
segmento especial dedicado a entender y
analizar los temas clave de esta carrera
hacia la casa blanca
la frontera entre colombia brasil y perú
es el hogar de 209 mil personas el 57%
de ellas pertenece a los pueblos
originarios de acuerdo con el análisis
que hace la universidad de johns hopkins
las zonas en las que habitan los
indígenas tienen una tasa de letalidad
por kobe 19 es decir el número de
muertes por cada 100 contagios
confirmados superior al 4% que a su vez
es mayor al promedio de cada uno de
estos tres países
la onu lanzó un plan de cooperación con
los gobiernos de estas naciones para
recaudar más de 10 millones de dólares
para proveer a las comunidades
alimentación acceso a agua y saneamiento
básico pero para algunos ya es tarde en
perú las mujeres de la amazona se
unieron para demandar al gobierno por
vulnerar les el derecho a la vida nos lo
cuenta nuestro corresponsal en lima
francisco zacarías
olinda silvano y sus amigas realizan un
ritual para alejar a las energías
negativas
[Música]
le piden a los espíritus de la etnia
shipibo conibo que ayuden a los pueblos
originarios del perú a resistir la
pandemia del cob y 19 están muriéndose
la gente por falta de médico medicina
por falta de atención no por parte del
estado que no apoya no se va muriendo
familia y familia no porque no hay gas
no hay el oxígeno no hay los
medicamentos colinda forma parte de la
organización nacional de mujeres
indígenas y amazónicas del perú conap
quien demandó al estado peruano lo
acusan de ponerlos en riesgo al
coronavirus y abandonarlos sin atención
de salud durante la cuarentena como
linda más de 21 mil indígenas
contrajeron el kobe y se estima que las
muertes pueden llegar a 3000 la acción
más concreta es ir subiendo como se dice
los diferentes espacios internacionales
y uno de ellos es la corte
interamericana de derechos humanos por
supuesto que antes de ello está la
comisión interamericana de derechos
humanos iremos todos los pasos que se
tiene que dar para alcanzar justicia
la defensoría del pueblo afirma que el
estado peruano destinó más de 20
millones de dólares para atender a los
pueblos originarios pero reconoce que
aún quedan grandes retos por resolver
hay una necesidad no solamente ahora
durante la pandemia sino de cara al
futuro de fortalecer el sistema de
atención de salud en estas en estos
lugares pero además también dotarles de
infraestructura adecuada en temas de por
ejemplo conectividad o línea silva no
venció al coronavirus ahora con energías
renovadas lucha para que el estado
peruano garantice sus derechos y los de
los pueblos originarios reconocidos y
protegidos por la constitución del país
desde 1920
argentina está de luto por la muerte de
kino el dibujante padre de la icónica
mafalda murió a los 88 años de edad la
niña que odia la sopa y defiende la
democracia dejó de ser dibujada en 1973
pero sus mensajes trascendieron al
tiempo y siguen siendo citados hoy la
obra de joaquín lavado fue traducida a
más de 33 idiomas que le valieron el
reconocimiento a nivel internacional
el monumento a mafalda y sus amigos en
buenos aires- se llenó de flores y
ofrendas y las redes sociales de
homenajes veamos
ahora aquí no ha cumplido el requisito
para ser inmortal larga vida a mafalda y
a todos los personajes que le rodean el
mundo llora la partida del dibujante
argentino quino decenas de
caricaturistas le rindieron homenaje en
redes sociales y es que las aventuras de
mafalda manolito susanita y felipe
influyeron en decenas de artistas de
toda américa latina que no tuvo esa
fórmula para para poder ir más allá del
contexto que estaba ocurriendo en ese
momento y además el humor universal es
como que difícil poder hacer una
disección de su humor es solamente
disfrutarlo y a lo largo de casi seis
décadas sus personajes le dieron la
vuelta al mundo en decenas de idiomas
las viñetas hicieron merecedor a joaquín
salvador lavado del premio príncipe de
asturias y la medalla de la orden y las
letras de francia en su natal mendoza
fue decretado el duelo mientras que en
el monumento en su honor en el
tradicional barrio de san telmo en
buenos aires sus seguidores fueron
la flor es el lugar para nosotros es muy
importante porque es casi un lugar de
peregrinación hay colas de turistas
todos los fines de semana pero hoy bueno
como es un día tan particular con la
pérdida que hemos tenido este me pareció
adecuado venir a saludar
a mafalda manolito y a susanita que hoy
están si todos nos sentimos un poco
huérfanos
ellos supongo que más mafalda la pequeña
amante de los beatles la democracia los
derechos de los niños y la paz apareció
por primera vez en 1964 aunque sus
atemporales mensajes por un mundo mejor
la hicieron inmortal y hoy de hecho
están más vigentes que nunca empezamos
nuestro segmento especial camino a la
casa blanca el espacio semanal para
seguir la contienda entre el presidente
de donald trump y el candidato demócrata
joe biden de cara a las elecciones
presidenciales del 3 de noviembre hoy
vamos a hablar del debate alrededor del
primer debate entre los candidatos
griterías insultos e interrupciones
marcaron el que ha sido calificado como
el peor cara a cara entre candidatos de
la historia de eeuu
el caos llevó a la comisión de debates
presidenciales un grupo no partidista
que organiza los encuentros desde 1988 a
anunciar cambios en el formato para
garantizar que los próximos encuentros
se realicen de manera ordenada y es que
payaso mentiroso el peor presidente de
la historia son solo algunos de los
mensajes intercambiados en el caótico
debate en el que el presidente camps se
concentró en destacar sus logros en su
actual mandato sin hacer propuestas para
el próximo iba a ir en aunque no logró
usar el valioso tiempo en televisión
para plantear su agenda mostró que no es
un anciano sin capacidades mentales como
lo han planteado algunos de sus rivales
sin embargo no pudo evitar caer en el
juego del mandatario según la cadena cbs
el presidente de trump interrumpió a byd
en 73 veces y el exvicepresidente a el
vamos a hablar en nueva york con nuestra
corresponsal mamen sanz a mamen empiezo
por preguntarte cuál es la influencia
histórica que han tenido de los debates
en el voto de los estadounidenses
si a natalia pues desde luego estos
debates son importantes aunque sí que es
cierto que a estas alturas y con la
situación atípica que se vive por esta
pandemia la mayoría de estadounidenses
ya han decidido cuál es su candidato
favorito pero todavía queda un 10% de
indecisos y precisamente asá hacia ese
10% se pretendía dirigir estos dos
candidatos más allá de que luego el
debate se complicará históricamente los
debates han sido muy importantes primero
porque nos permiten ver a los candidatos
en su estado natural segundo porque en
principio salvo lo que vimos este martes
permite a los ciudadanos ver un poco
cuáles van a ser sus propuestas en caso
de que lleguen o se mantengan en la casa
blanca y lo hemos visto históricamente
lo vimos ya por ejemplo en el primer
debate televisivo que tuvo lugar que fue
cuando jhon kennedy y ganó en ese debate
a un nixon que llegó pues enfermo con
fiebre que además se había olvidado de
afeitar y que desde luego le dio muchos
motivos a su contrincante para ganarlo
lo vimos también con
bush padré cuando en ese debate
televisado- también miraba a la hora y
los votantes lo interpretaron como que
se estaba aburriendo y tampoco le
permitió llegar a su victoria así que
estos debates son fundamentales y muy
importantes porque la imagen y la
actitud de los candidatos también dice
mucho a los votantes pero desde luego
nada que ver con lo que vimos este
martes que se salió completamente de las
reglas y de cualquier papel de lo que
habíamos visto hasta ahora
últimamente y cuáles son estas
reglamentaciones que la comisión de los
debates presidenciales podría cambiar
para organizar que el intercambio de
ideas sea mejor
si la comisión de debates ha dejado
claro que desde luego no está dispuesto
a que el espectáculo de gritos
enfrentamientos y tiranteces que vimos
el martes se repita por un lado tenemos
al candidato demócrata joe biden que ya
ha dicho que lo que vimos este martes
fue una auténtica vergüenza nacional y
por otro lado tenemos al equipo de
campaña de donald trump que insiste en
que cualquier cambio en las reglas del
debate no es bueno y en la comisión de
debates hace oídos sordos a lo que pide
el presidente y está dispuesto a cambiar
como dices las reglas del juego estas
reglas todavía están se están decidiendo
cómo se van a implementar pero de
momento hemos conocido que lo que sí que
se va a hacer seguramente es cortar los
micrófonos y los candidatos no respetan
sus turnos es algo que como digo veremos
y se confirmará en los próximos días
pero desde luego en los debates del 15 y
del 22 de octubre vamos a ver unas
reglas diferentes a ese a ese caos que
vivimos el pasado martes
amén y podríamos decir entonces que el
debate en general es el gran perdedor
el debate en general es el gran perdedor
yo más bien diría que son los propios
estadounidenses los que perdieron porque
fue imposible entender nada entre tanto
grito e interrupción y esas peleas y
golpes bajos que vimos para que os
hagáis una idea si normal si el año 2016
hubo 84 millones de estadounidenses que
siguieron el primer debate este año
muchos apagaron su televisor y tan solo
28 7 millones de estadounidenses
siguieron este primer debate por hacer
algún tipo de lectura positiva lo que sí
que pudimos ver en este debate es un
reflejo de cómo está la sociedad
estadounidense en este momento
tremendamente polarizada y desde luego
con mucha tensión después de 8 meses ya
de pandemia como dices ninguno de los
dos tuvo la oportunidad de dejar claro
cuál era su programa y la verdad es que
fue terrible que esos gritos y esos
enfrentamientos dejarán en segundo plano
cuestiones tan importantes como cuál va
a ser el futuro de la corte suprema- qué
va a pasar con la situación económica
desastrosa que vive el país en estos
momentos cómo se va a gestionar
pandemia y varios temas más que por
supuesto pues quedaron un poco
desdibujados en medio de tanto
enfrentamiento insultos golpes bajos y
gritos y bueno y fue imposible seguir el
hilo de lo que cada uno de los
candidatos
quería poner encima de la mesa en caso
de que llegara a la casa blanca por
parte del del candidato demócrata o que
se mantuviera en ella por parte del
presidente de donald trump gracias en
nueva york' a mamen sala en nuestra
corresponsal por estar en este segmento
especial de aquí américa camino a la
casa blanca y que sigue en esta carrera
el debate de los vicepresidentes del 7
de octubre en salt lake city el actual
vicepresidente mike pence se enfrenta a
la compañera de baile en kamala harris
en un cara a cara que se dividirá en
segmentos de 10 minutos que se prevé
incluir en la discusión sobre la
economía el coronavirus y la
discriminación racial
gracias por acompañarme en esta emisión
recuerden que pueden seguirme en redes
sociales en la dirección que ven en sus
pantallas cuídense mucho del coronavirus
y sigan viendo france24
[Música]
r efe